sitting here listening to my music list
and I'm starting to find a little
clarity starting to understand why this
thing is so hard being a bunch of the
worship [ __ ] this game a life it's
because the real answer is really found
when you're pulling from opposite
directions
send your label saying why why why am I
so glass wise all this good stuff
happening and if you think I'm a
contradiction because I'm I've got this
funny juxtaposition where I'm pulling
from opposite directions
I don't even [ __ ] with anything think
about me yet hoping to every comment and
I'll listen to everything all of you say
about me Clarissa I talk of fuckload I'm
always talking of cut people off of
talking but I'm listening I'm listening
24/7 I'm a Cory's patient a playing the
long game but most quick things every
day try and testing not crippled by
stopping starting how do I figure that
out how do I understand when it's time
to give up on something or when it's
time to persevere how do I understand
how do I feel
and how do I decide when to listen
somebody's feedback or to know when
they're trolling or don't give a [ __ ] or
only search
service-level how how is this happening
how am i working 24/7 365 yet doesn't
feel like I'm working how am I only
constantly putting out content building
my brand yet never thinking about it
just living my life how am i documenting
instead of creating where is this where
is this then coming from where is this
call to action coming from why is this
brand working so well now how do I get
all these youngsters and when I say
youngsters I mean the 59 year old
present blown up yet who hasn't been
willing to look at the world and it
comes from there it comes from the most
macro it cleared up from them sort of
see it it's understanding that nobody
gives a [ __ ] and that that's okay and
that's the way it should be
I live on empathy you shouldn't give a
[ __ ] you got you to worry about I'm
empathetic to that that's the game and
we'll all deal with different cards
we've all got strengths and weaknesses
we've got the advantages and the
disadvantages you see white privilege so
do i I see privilege and being from the
streets and having zero and being hungry
there's so many different ways and of
course some are better than others the
most back-row but I don't even spend the
time to figure that out
because by the time you figure out if it
was fair [ __ ] finished and so instead
of doing that I do and I do and I do and
I'm always planning and I'm not planning
and I've always got a game plan and a
strategy and I've always not that one
I'm just going off the hip from
intuition from learned behavior for
pattern recognition because I've been
doing this from again
when I was 12 13 14 15 I knew I did it's
why I got there sugary
shadows everybody saw that what I got on
Instagram you know it's what I do and so
as I sit here lay and look and think and
debate and look at the auction and
listen to this music it's becoming clear
2017 could be a great year not just for
me but for you because I find clarity
I'm going to suffocate negativity I'm
going to suffocate excuses if you're
going to be in my community you can't
give up and leave if you want to believe
in those things because I'm going to
pound it push it press it harder than I
ever had before because of youth is I'm
thankful I'm grateful I'm working on
myself
24/7 my goals my ambitions and I'm
working on your goals and your ambitions
24/7 that Corrib opposite direction
that's what I do that's what I do harder
stronger better than anybody
honey Empire [ __ ] build the biggest
building of all time the biggest best
business of all time like a [ __ ]
tortoise like a slow [ __ ] tortoise
ship away everyday underestimated all
along the way
got my fans who are delusional I got the
rest of the majority of the market that
doesn't think I can get it that doesn't
see the behavior because they're
thinking 2017
they're stating 2019 they're thinking
2021 of taking flight [ __ ] I'm
thinking [ __ ] life and so I
promise you community the people that
are listening to this right now you've
given me the greatest [ __ ] gift of
all you keep your $500 bastard classes
you keep your $5,000 master Minds you
keep your $97 books you keep that in
your pocket if you do you your gifting
me with the greatest
on earth your attention at your word of
mouth every [ __ ] time tag somebody at
my comment on Instagram every time you
share my story on snapchat every time
you post and share on Facebook means the
world to me every retweet means the
world to me
that means you're putting me on your
co-signing this [ __ ] journey and for
that
for granted I love you app 2017
Oh
[Music]